welcome
um my talk actually probably
dovetails nicely with just the previous
talk it'll be about my a learner's
journey in using desk to help us speed
up the production of our Transit data
set that we're putting onto the
California open data portal so my name
is Tiffany Chu I'm a data scientist at
Caltrans which is the State Department
of Transportation
um within Caltrans where I work is a
division called the California
integrated travel project and this is a
Statewide initiative that started in
2018 uh to really modernize our
transportation experience
broadly speaking our work uh touches on
three things standardized trip planning
information contactless payments and
automatic automating customer discounts
and so I'll focus on the first which is
trip planning information
today
um
so
the bulk of our data in our warehouse is
gtfs data which is the general Transit
feed specification it's all things that
about public transit service and
essentially it's everything you need to
pull up Google Maps and ask I want to
get from point A to point B using
Transit how can I do it so it's
everything behind that and that's what
we ingest in our data warehouse
uh it's a very rich data set we can
answer a lot of things from it
one of the things that we answer is
where are high quality Transit areas
so by Statute
caltransit is required to make this
available
uh these corridors and these areas near
major Transit are areas that would get
land uses that support walkability
density and active Transportation so
it's really important to know like where
these places are and we've been required
to
make this available for the last 20
years and we haven't really been able to
until now
but now that we have gtfs data and you
know gtfs is public
um it just makes sense that as we're
kind of deriving these outputs from it
we also make that publicly available and
that's why we put it onto our open data
portal
so
why now
you ask well in figuring out where these
areas are it requires a lot of
geospatial processing that we were doing
in Python and because we were working
with Transit operators in the state it
was big and we wanted to make this data
available frequently so right now we're
publishing on a monthly kids
and so dasc integrated nicely with our
existing workflow because first it
integrates with python and as a big data
tool you're not going to have the memory
issues that you might run into with
pandas
uh the fact that like each run was
taking 10 hours a month combined with
the fact that we wanted to run this very
frequently meant figuring out a way and
a solution that would make this
sustainable in the long run
and so
uh I didn't want to tie up my own
Computing resources for 10 hours a month
and so I kind of embarked on this
effort to really scale and to optimize
um and I found that the most valuable
thing that came from using desk was it
forced me to think about
what step was sequential what step did
it need to be sequential and could be
paralyzed
and really kind of modularizing the code
so that we could keep using our outputs
in a smarter way
um
when we're working with large data sets
sometimes we use Loops as this
convenient way for us to avoid having
like memory issues or crashing your
kernel
but Loops become this way of imposing a
sequential framework
and what I mean by that is you know
we're doing something to Transit
operator number one we finished and we
move on to number two the number three
when the order doesn't matter and we
could really
do the same kind of processing
simultaneously on all the operators at
once and so that makes it perfect for
using desk because we're able to kind of
move things away from sequential
uh our version one kind of it was 10
hours it just used pandas but even
simply switching over to desk data
frames
um helped us cut the time down in half
and then a later iteration really
focused in on what things are relieving
sequential and how could we remove it
um but it's very iterative and so now
on the horizon is well we've been doing
this locally on our local cluster can we
move it to the cloud cluster and it
makes sense now to set one up
so
I'm gonna walk through some of the text
of the legislation and help translate
that into maybe more discrete code
Concepts that we can use so the
definition of a high quality Transit
Corridor is a corridor with fixed route
bus service with service that's at least
15 minutes during peak hours and the
idea of corridors is very nebulous so we
bring in this this concept of equally
sized line segments
um no longer than 15 minutes service
simply means every hour we see at least
four trips passed by at that stop
and if there's like multiple stops on
that same segment we'll keep the stop
that has the highest number of trips
and for peak hours we'll deal with the
day in two time periods so before noon
and after noon and see which hour has
the most stops or sorry the most trips
that hour
and so
kind of show you how all these Concepts
come into play our starting point here
is the physical coverage of just one bus
route
we start with this idea
and
when we look at a bus route we can
understand like it travels eastbound it
travels travels Westbound and in gtfs
this would be captured in two rows with
two different shapes but if we bring
them together we get this top Navy line
and we can immediately bring in
geopandas and shapely to help cut the
Slime into segments and figure out does
this segment run east west or north
south
and then with desk we can look across
all the segments for that route
and say this route is now it's an
East-West route or it's a Northwest
route north south from
and with desk we have to bring in a
pretty big table it's big because it has
a row for every time a bus makes a stop
so if it arrives at a bus stop there's a
row and we use desk to parse the
timestamp which comes as a string
and we figure out what departure hour
it's a like what departure is in and we
can count for this thought in this hour
how many trips took place
and we can look across all the hours you
know in the AM and say okay at this stop
what was the highest number of trips
that were made
so we bring in desk geopanners to do our
spatial join so stops our points they
have lat long and they need to be
attached to segments so we'll draw a
little buffer and we ask where does this
stop this point fall into this kind of
elongated polygon now and if there are
multiple stops in a segment we'll just
keep the one that has the most number of
trips
and with that we can very easily see
where are there for more than four trips
an hour and that is flagged as being yes
it is a high quality Transit corridor
so the next concept we bring in is well
what the major Transit stop
what I will skip today is the fact that
rail fairy bus Rapid Transit is also
part of this definition
but I'll focus on the most geospatially
complex which is where there is an
intersection of two or more major bus
routes with at least 15 minute frequency
during peak hours
and we will use that idea that we've
just figured out um these segments and
figure out all right which two intersect
each other
um and immediately you're probably
thinking
geopandis clipping geopandas overlay
that's probably the idea I want to use
uh
but let's dive a little deeper and ask
what do we really mean when we say they
intersect yes we mean these two routes
touch
um but we also mean a lot more than that
and so in this diagram here you can see
that there's three bus routes
at the Street intersection and when we
think of two routes intersecting we only
think of route a and Route c as
intersecting we think of Route B and C
as intersecting but we do not think of
routes A and B as intersecting and why
is that it's because route A and B run
in the same direction so technically
their lines would basically run the top
of each other they touch but we don't
think of that as an intersection
and so there's two ideas that we can
glean from this picture the first is
geography matters uh the routes have to
be close to each other in space so
routes in Los Angeles are not going to
run into routes in San Francisco
um and the second idea is Direction
matters so specifically perpendicular
directions if they run perpendicularly
to each other they are allowed to
intersect
so what can we do with these two ideas
to help us well what we'd like to create
is this pairwise table where we say like
okay this East-West route intersects
with this north-south route
but there's so many combinations like
how can we do this clipping is very
expensive we don't want to try all the
combinations out there so desk geopandos
which does not have overlay but does
have clipping and spatial join so we use
the idea of spatial join with desk which
is we ask do these two routes intersect
yes or no
it doesn't tell us that area of
intersection
that's not what a spatial joint does but
it tells you yes or no they intersect or
no and with that we're able to quickly
narrow down to just the valid pairs that
we'd like to cycle through in order to
find the area of intersection
and what this
actually leaves us with is over a
hundred thousand Pairs and so if we're
not doing this and we're just trying all
the combinations out there we're really
trying a number that's magnitudes
greater than that
um
the next thing is
in a version three okay in this pairwise
table I'm noticing that I only keep
East-West routes with north south routes
but how I was implementing that was I
was trying all these combinations and
then removing rows where the direction
was the same
and version three really brings that
second idea of direction to the
Forefront
to say wait a minute I don't need to
remove it after the fact why don't I
just allow East-West routes to be
spatially joined to North South routes
to begin with and that does it in a much
simpler cleaner clear way
and once this whole pairwise table is
set up
uh I actually end up moving away from
desk because all this work has lent
itself to use geopandis intersection
really nicely which is it just does a
row wise comparison and it gives you
that area of intersection between the
two and that's exactly what we want
so here's some code it it's supposed to
be illustrative and not to be
overwhelming
but in version one it's cycling through
kind of all the combinations out there
to do the clipping
um it's trying a lot of combinations
that end up not adding anything to our
results and so the step takes hours and
we need to do something
different
in version two it this idea of geography
comes into play so
this idea of like different operators
being in different areas is much easier
to figure out because you have you know
very different regions in the state and
you can quickly figure out which ones
might touch each other or intersect each
other
but for routes within the same operator
they're basically running in the same
service area so
it's still looping through to try all
the combinations because chances are
out in Los Angeles intersecting with
another route in Los Angeles yeah it's
like it's pretty high
um
so this I mean it's better it's less
than an hour
but we can do better
we must
um and so here version three it brings
that second idea Direction into play and
it just says all right in my spatial
drawing you have to be in different
directions and I'll spatially join you
to figure out if you're ever valid and
then quickly I'll throw you in with
geopandas to find the Arab intersection
this is really fast it's really clean
it's really simple it takes less than a
minute
um
and so here's kind of our result this is
what's put on our open data portal this
is San Diego and you have we have a
couple of different types of book
qualifies and this is what we'd like to
make available to the public
at least on a monthly Cadence
and so what were my lessons learned uh
well first
we should use a big data tool like desk
to handle memory issues and not Loops so
in version one you probably need Loops
to just get some visibility into what
you're working on to make sure you know
what you intend to execute is actually
being done
but don't leave them in place uh simply
just because you don't want to crash
your kernel use the right tool to handle
like a memory issue
and the second thing is well
more on that
when we leave Loops in place we leave
things that
we leave things to be sequential when
they need not be there they can be done
simultaneously they can be done in a
parallelized fashion and
you know
trying to think of ways to remove Loops
really forces us to think
yeah like are we doing this in a really
thoughtful way
the second lesson is well write rewrite
I mean I cannot emphasize this more
rewrite rewrite rewrite uh for me this
workflow was the first time I ever used
desk and so
it's this whole Suite of tools it's like
a grab bag I didn't know where to begin
and what to use but every time I rewrote
I got to use more and more of the tools
and kind of look at what bottlenecks
remained what were the pain points and
what can I use from this whole grab bag
that can address the pain point that
remains
and right now like all the things I've
talked about the gains and time like
they're all done locally but now the
code is much more set up for moving it
to the cloud
and the last lesson is well sometimes
the best optimization you can do is
really going back to the basics and
trying to get the most out of your
pre-processing steps and so I found the
exercise was trying to match what I was
writing in my code with how I was
talking about it how was I explaining it
a lot of times we write in a more
complicated way than how we would
explain it and bringing that together
and simplifying the code to match
exactly what I was saying was really
critical and if that meant moving away
from desk
that was okay I can mix and match and
use the different tools I needed I
didn't need to stay only in pandas only
in desk but I could just mix and match
in every stage
um
and that that's a wrap so I've left my
team's GitHub here as well as contact
information and a site for all of the
analytics work that my team is also
working on so thank you
thank you for this awesome talk
um I'm sure we've learned a lot and uh
any questions are welcome
we have a question
what other Technologies did you consider
so for us we
just considered desk and it played well
with
basically our data warehouse and our Hub
so our Jupiter notebook environment is
in a hub it's in the cloud and we're
connected with our warehouse which is
bigquery and so dasc had
the other I guess all the ways that we
could connect
from where our data was how we were
working on it easily and so we just
started with with desk